If one wishes to find the gold of life, they
must be willing to dig and sift through the
dirt.
When thinking about life, it becomes very
easy to drown in its immense complexity and
uncertainty.
It becomes appealing to just claim ignorance
and pretend like such complexity does not
exist.
But pretending that life is simple does not
make it so.
Regardless of how much one may try, no one
can be completely numb to the effects of life.
The only real way to simplify life is by following
it down its path of complexity.
We must not run from its intricate and elusive
nature.
We must, instead, accept and embrace it.
Only then can we break life down into small
enough pieces to understand.
Consider the basic food ingredient, a tomato.
Think about how many edible applications there
are for a tomato.
You can eat it whole.
You can cut it up into big chunks and put
it on a salad.
You can slice it into small slivers and put
it on a burger.
You can dice it and put it in soup or on top
of a chicken meal.
You can smash it up and make it into a sauce
for a pasta meal, or pizza, or a sandwich.
You can blend it with the addition of other
ingredients and make it into ketchup or a
soup broth.
The recipes and applications for a tomato
are endless, but one can only uncover them
if they break the tomato down.
The more one breaks it down into smaller and
smaller pieces, the more usages the tomato
has and the easier it is to manipulate into
different meals.
Life works the same way.
Individuals who are willing to cut up, break
down, and analyze complicated thoughts and
ideas are able to turn them into delicious
meals in the form of solutions, art, or understanding.
All things in life do not require over-complication,
but it is the fear of facing the things that
do that prevents legitimate simplification
and well-being.
It is this fear that leaves us hopelessly
lost from who can be and what we can experience
in life.
It is this fear that we must overcome.
It is the tomato that we must cut through.